le tardigrade
regarder le avec sa drôle de tête on le
surnomme aussi lourd son dos ce petit
animal de moins d'un millimètre et doté
de huit peta est un champion des
conditions extrêmes il résiste à des
températures allant de - 273 degrés à
plus 150 degrés il est capable de vivre
au plus profond des océans au beau
milieu des déserts ou encore au sommet
des plus hautes montagnes
il peut se priver d'eau et de nourriture
pendant des décennies les rayons x ne
lui font presque aucun effet il survit
même dans l'espace c'est
vraisemblablement le seul animal qu'ils
soient présents sur la lune il ne s'y
est pas rendue tout seul en 2019 une
sondhi a été envoyée avec à son bord
mille tardigrade alors même si nous
n'avons pas de nouvelles d'eux depuis eh
bien il est fort probable car une telle
capacité certains aient survécu